good morning Morgan today is Monday
March 15 20 30 to developed by the
Austin branch of dishonored developer
Arkane studios prey is described as a
reimagining of the original 2006 game
waking up as Morgan you you're ready to
start your day at Transtar headquarters
but like every good sci-fi narrative
something goes terribly wrong just a
heads up this is the opening 12 minutes
of the game so major spoiler warning for
up-to-date coverage of prey hit
subscribe but for now let's see how
Morgan's adventure begins
[Music]
morning mister you
heard there's a chopper on the roof must
be for you
[Music]
[Music]
please make yourself comfortable
the facility is just a short
there's cars
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
class operator
welcome I am appointment in the testing
facility
please confirmed
[Music]
Morgan finally hey you don't look
terrible than a transfer uniform how's
your eye still red I know the tests
might seem a little unconventional but
it's a new family tradition breakin
convention is in our blood wouldn't you
start the tests just do whatever comes
natural don't overthink it
dr. Bellamy is gonna walk you through
the process you're in good hands
we'll be in orbit next week I promise
mr. Yu they're ready for your brother
and mume right listen just be yourself
I'll see you after
good morning Morgan I'm dr. Bellamy
looks like we have some tests to run
through today probably not the kind of
thing you're used to I imagine but trust
me you're going to do fantastic all good
great let's begin for this first test
I'd like you to remove the boxes from
the red circle as quickly as you can
just go with your gut okay wonderful
press the red button when you're ready
[Music]
absolutely fine let's move on okay
Morgan listen carefully I'd like you to
do your best to hide in this room take
your time relax think it over
no I'm kidding you only have nine
seconds hit the red button when you're
ready to start
[Music]
is he he's hiding behind the chair hmm
any synaptic register at all no no
that's fine
sorry let's keep things moving Morgan
head into rooms see you're doing
marvelous all right here we go
for this test please press the blue
button across the room as quickly as you
can in the most natural intuitive way
possible without thinking just just go
for it press the red button when you're
ready I'm sorry can someone please
explain to me what's happening
Simon I installed exactly what Tina
brought down did you double-check
they're still on
I apologize Morgan we're having some
trouble with the equipment not your
fault
you're doing fabulous actually one last
room let's step into deed
can someone get me a cup of coffee I
would appreciate it thank you okay
Morgan have a seat at the table show me
please wonderful job
take a look at the screen in front of
you I'm going to show you a series of
questions pick the answer that makes the
most sense to you press start on the
screen when you're ready
good looks like you've got the hang of
it keep going
that's heavy stuff
good next
almost done
interesting well done well done we're
nearly through it for this next part I'm
going to display an image I want you to
take a good look at it in a moment I'm
going to ask you what
you